foreign
we need to have a tool to where a person
who's not listening to the Ramsey show
the Ken Coleman show or coming to the
smart conference could be self-assessed
and get those elements very clear and
then have a purpose statement to where
they could see at a high level this
is what I was created to do and then
have the freedom to look in the
marketplace and see well I could go here
I could do this I could do this all of
which allow me to be uniquely me and so
that was the impetus behind the tool so
from the CEO seat of course I approved
the process that you all went through to
do this and saw the updates on the
product as it was being developed and I
was just getting by I keep my eyes on a
few things and that was one of them that
was happening didn't think anything more
about it and then I get an email from
you the other day hey take the
assessment yeah and I'm like dude I kind
of know what I'm supposed to do don't
take the assessment right now I know
what I'm supposed to do he goes no I
want to see if it works on you yeah and
I thought well let's see if the stupid
thing works and so I took it and the
stupid thing works yeah it nailed it
yeah so uh can I read your do you want
to read it or are you read it all right
so so I told you all you get the three
elements Talent passion Mission now
here's what the report does you get a
detailed report yeah one page that says
here are your top three here are your
mid-range talents and then here's the
stuff quite frankly you suck at and and
it's okay because because you're not
supposed to focus much on that and so we
do that with passion stuff that Dave
loves so talents what he's good at
passion what Dave loves to do and then
mission is what motivates Dave what
motivates Dave to come in and so here is
his statement I was created to use my
talents of persuasion instruction and
communication to perform my passions of
leading promoting and Performing to
accomplish my mission of influence by
producing change in progress now if that
doesn't sound like Dave Ramsey I don't
know what does and and so what this does
not for Dave but for anybody who's a
little bit confused maybe lacking some
confidence it gives them a chance to see
themselves as the world sees them how
they are uniquely put together and that
purpose statement is a high level job
description for a couple reasons number
one for the person who's maybe a college
student or someone who's just been
wandering they can now begin to have a
North star a compass and then for
someone who's in it and starting to
wonder should I stay with it because I'm
going through a valley which happens
then what it does for them is gives them
tremendous confidence and courage to
stay and so that's what this tool does
clarity and confidence I think I'm a
simpleton every time I take one of these
things of any kind it completely Nails
me well I mean 40 years ago I took the
disc the disc and I came out 98 D 98 I
and I came on my handed it to my wife we
had never seen anything like these kinds
of Assessments back in those days you
know hand it to her we were sitting
there talking and she's reading it
she's like yep yep yep this is what's
wrong with you what's wrong with me that
is me it's not what's wrong with me and
then she took it and she is determined
as an sc that that's the proper thing to
be and all the rest of us are wrong well
she makes a picture after 30 years
that's not how this works but all right
right uh and then I took the Enneagram
my friend Ian cron right oh sure and uh
he like I wrote eight for you oh yeah
it's like you are the quintessential
Enneagram eight exactly when you see a
freaking autobiography right the
pictures next to it yeah and this thing
here man it got it hit it I mean
persuasion instruction communication to
lead to promote to perform to have
influence and that's what we do here I
mean that's a lot what a lot of Ramsay
does for that matter because it comes
out of the you know out of the DNA of
the leader and the founder that's
exactly right and so um yeah this thing
is it's the get clear assessment folks
and uh how much is it you ready for this
it's only ten dollars until the end of
October so you only have a few days left
for the whole month of October we've
reduced it from thirty dollars to ten
dollars and here's what's great about it
it's digital now you can do a printout
like we did here but you're also going
to get a PDF it'll send you the download
on your own 30 page report that really
goes deep and it's very impressive I
mean when you read through it I'm just
like yep yeah yeah wonderful gift by the
way you know you've got a college kid
coming out of college trying to figure
out what to do well or somebody just
husband kind of struggling you've got
friends that are in the in between spot
yeah it's like I don't know man I
thought I knew this and I don't know
anything and there's something
um
it kind of when you don't know where you
are like that there it it dashes your
confidence yes sure does and you don't
you don't have the uh I don't know the
energy to move forward on stuff when
you're not sure when you're unsure
here's how I talk about it if you've
ever driven in a downpour of rain and it
comes on you quickly a deluge or
tremendous fog you immediately pull the
car over you slow down first
tremendously you slow down and you pull
over why you can't see past the hood of
the car this is the same way in our work
in our career and purpose that if we're
not quite sure we're not clear on where
we're going and why we're going what do
we do we pull back and it's the
paralysis by analysis and a tool like
this uncovers who you are get the
results run them by somebody who knows
you really well get some feedback and
it'll give you that added confidence to
be uh who you were created to be well
and I'm convinced that the um the
algorithm that we put together to do
this is unbelievably accurate so yeah it
is I mean it certainly nailed me no
questions very smart people that can do
all this yeah